buona sera io sono stato un ei e first
student era il 1981 i miei figli mi
chiedevano ma avevate la televisione a
colori perché è inconcepibile che non ci
fossero i videogame ma neanche la
televisione a colori ed era le stesse
domande che mi facevano quando arriva in
america le ragioni per cui sono qua sono
tante sono più per un invito che ho
accolto con stupore
c'è gente molto più qualificata a
parlare fs di intercultura stasera
abbiamo avuto dei viaggi un viaggio
fotografico un viaggio all'interno di
una storia di un paese abbiamo avuto un
viaggio all'interno delle persone e
anch'io ho un piccolo viaggio
il mio viaggio è a 16 anni partire
partire ci vuole coraggio e ci vuole
curiosità
il credo siano due delle cose che
caratterizzano l'esperienza di
intercultura o qualunque scambio e io a
16 anni aveva un'idea dell'america
hollywood dallas
voi non sapete cosa sia dinasty le faide
per me new york la quinta strada era
tutta in davi in giro per una città era
quinta strada fini o no questo è il mio
modo gli amici della high school erano
happy days the forms questa era drive in
american graffiti chi non ha visto le
macchine e questa era l'idea di che cosa
si facesse di pomeriggio e sono arrivato
con un impatto diverso arrivo prima in
una città poi risposto in un'altra
questa è fisicamente la mia casa
questa la mia dallas questo e mi
american graffiti
questa è la mia fifth avenue perché
dov'ero io c'erano laghi io ero a new
jersey soltanto a 30 minuti dalla new
jersey tra bike più all'interno dove c'è
un lago che fa da riserva d'acqua di new
york ma nella parte interna dove c'è un
più piccolo lago si chiama one agi
e qua avviene tutto e questa è la mia
scuola
questo impatto perché questo è stato un
anno ed è una mincu io ho vissuto ho
cambiato amici ho cambiato tante cose ma
fondamentalmente ho scoperto due cose
importanti la prima è chi sei che tu sai
chi sei
ovunque tu sia puoi cambiare il suo
atteggiamento
la seconda cosa è che la gente si
aspetta da te delle cose
indipendentemente dalle cose che sono si
aspetta anche quelle cose io arrivo il
primo giorno mi portano in macchina
scuola entro cioè la curva dopo la porta
escono quando usciamo mi devo far
trovare il parcheggio è perché mi
vengano a prendere in macchina
c'è una ragazza che arriva con tre libri
30 fogli non quelle classiche che
cercava per la macchina quindi appoggio
un libro sulla macchina del capo un
foglio io mi avvicino le apre la
portiera
lei mi guarda sorride ma non è il
sorriso di una che ti butti sorride per
gentilezza di stupore chiariamoci aprire
porte per me a 16 anni è una cosa che si
faceva per la ragazza al cinema non si
in america a 16 anni si guida tu puoi
aprire la porta una ragazza a milano in
bicicletta in motorino non si apre porte
a piena porta un autobus del possibile
ap la porta alla scuola per far passare
le due ragazze che mi guardano e
sorridono che io sono diventato il
cascamorto miller
io ho scoperto che le ragazze si
attardavano quando arrivavo per farsi
aprire la porta
prima una base attività ma voi non avete
idea di cosa causata rim buddha la
guerra perché ogni singolo fidanzato
amante candidato a questo punto aveva
una problematica e correvano al prese
porta la cultura si basa sul fatto di
avere dei comportamenti condivisi che
aiutano i componenti ad avere
atteggiamenti accettabili o familiari io
ero in una nuova cultura
conoscevo gente nuova vedevo cose nuove
e qualche ci voleva coraggio ma questo è
quello che gli fs mi ha permesso di fare
in maniera semplice ma c'è un percorso
più importante il percorso è quello che
mi ha permesso di fare delle cose
altrimenti non avrei mai fatto
grazie a l'esperienza ha imparato delle
piccole lezioni tra cui la lezione
numero uno mai mai mai mai mai
arrendersi mai mai mai darsi per vinto e
mai mai mai prendere in giro non
underdogs sneijder dog è colui che parte
svantaggiato ma vince questa è una droga
che ce la fa
l'under doghe è la vinci che batte
serena williams che chiede i'm sorry
come home saint comes to this may day
ansa
avvio sono stato l'underdog perché vanno
messe la squadra di football solo perché
ero veloce non pensate non ho fatto
nulla di eclatante ma ero molto veloce e
mi allenavo con gli altri ero parte
della squadra ma io facevo lo scalo
scaldapanchina mio passato i primi due
mesi a scaldar perché ma ho capito che
far parte della squadra voleva dire
partecipare alla squadra anche nella
panchina
io sono bravo a leggere i giochi sono
sempre stato bravo a capire le cose come
si muovevano e quando ho detto a mia
croce in una partita in cui perdavamo
brutalmente io l'ho intonso bianco
bellissimo tutti sporchi di fango
io dico croce sulla sulla destra il
crono a me qua ce la fa è sguarnito
pensando che facesse giocare e dice ok
si guardi in giro il porta il portato
era stanco anche lui la mascotte era a
pezzi
ce l'ho io mi manda in campo prima
azione io vengo messo per terra mi
saltano addosso sulla testa bevendo
l'acqua dalle pozzanghere
la seconda azione me la ricordo i più b
mi dice paolo 10 dentro io allo snap 10
ad dentro tanto vedo che lui mit volta
le spalle sta guardando kevin kevin è il
numero 88 io il numero 16
nessuno volesse dice al football 88 e
ricevitore e tira quello che viene
chiamato un grand tour home sales è una
bordata dritta sono che piove piove a
dirotto
kevin prende la palla gli rimbalza in
mezzo le mani piene nel casco e la palla
carambola palla liberachi la pigna sua
io sto correndo
e a chi arriva la palla qua io la prendo
eri la vocina corico e corri corri corri
corri corri e io corro ma io sono il
tipico italiano
io sono 190 tipica italiana sono con un
ottimo accento italiano ma se non altro
il suo veloce io corro mi fermo al
safety mi si butta in mezzo alle gambe
io mi alzo santo lico può fregar in quel
momento ma arrivano strong safety e io
faccio quello che in gergo si chiama fra
gli ufo
faccio due giri su me stesso a terra
sono a pezzi sono una pozzanghera esco
fuori sono bagnato cioè la sabbia cio
laccio a terra qua mi fa male mani ti
dico adesso il coach come sempre mi
chiamerà fuori
rimango in campo esco la pesca del mio
game quando riesco io sono i dettagli a
messa o di un panino e da quel giorno
sono luoghi sono l'underdog e sono stato
accettato e devi che inizia la mia
avventura perché lì che faccio gli amici
e quando la mia avventura finisce in un
vasto il 12 di giugno dove ci sono
ragazze che si abbracciano c'è la tua
fidanzata c'è tutto lì che al momento
del santo perché tu sei vuoto è triste
perché stai partendo per un nuovo
viaggio stai tornando ma ti porti dietro
un nuovo bagaglio e questo è il bagaglio
che mi ha permesso di andare avanti e di
fare altre cose io poi sono tornati in
america per studiare ho fatto un master
ho lavorato solo persistente sassoni ho
lavorato credo in tre continenti ho
avuto la fortuna di lavorare in società
che mi hanno permesso di accedere gente
straordinaria perché ho imparato quattro
piccole regole
è la prima regola è kim work il lavoro
di squadra
i lavori squadra non era italiana non mi
fraintendete non c'entra nulla il team
work come ve l'hanno insegnato la
società americana funziona che la
famiglia il quartiere la tua municipali
che il tuo sindaco se tu sei in grado di
contribuire
attualmente proprio spazio
ed è quest'ultimo a linz lombardi è uno
dei più grandi allenatori di food
americano ed è il gioco di squadra
inteso come elemento differenziante
nella società perché funziona così anche
il governo degli stati uniti con tutte
le pecche che ha il secondo punto
importante che ho imparato stando nel
campo da football grazie fs ma poi
lavorando per investment bank e fondi di
private equity che soltanto chi sa
obbedire si capisce cosa deve fare
può permettersi di comandare perché
comandare non è uno che vi dice cosa
fare però ne comandare quel imperare
un leader vi spiega la missione dove
vogliamo andare
ma lo fa perché anche lui ha capito come
farlo e c'è una delegazione di potere
quando voi parlate con un responsabile
americano
l'ultimo della catena in quel momento
voi parlate col più alto in grado a lui
viene demandato il potere non si
approfitta perché se fa male il suo
lavoro verrà punito
non sarà più di non potrà andare avanti
nella sua carriera e questo è stato
importante perché in consulenza siano
davvero dare gli ordini ai miei clienti
gli devo essere bravo a fare quella ad
aiutarlo a raggiungerlo la cosa più
importante da italiano che ha imparato
nella high school e seguire le regole
compilare i moduli compilare bene i
moduli ma ha permesso di andare a far
application chi e scuole in cui
sinceramente io ho 16 anni non ci
pensavo io sto avuto l'opportunità di
andare a studiare in tre grandi scuole
ho scelto worth non ce l'ha più elitaria
scuola di business
chiedo al mondo lì ho trovato gente dove
io devo andare dando di nuovo ma è fare
bene
i moduli non prenderò scorciatoia in
america c'era concetto che ci thing is
dead
infatti ti permettono di portare i libri
agli esami perché perché tanto poi
copiata un libro ma se non sai dove devi
guardare che che copia fare chi lascia
libro non devi imbrogliare un altro
senso
non devi prenderti scorciatoie se devi
fare una cosa fa la falla bene se non
sei capace alza la mano di juan
ma l'ultima cosa più bella che ho
imparato a essere prima t cd4 voto buono
ammetto anni 80 ci voleva bono dove
essere pragmatici vuol dire rimboccarsi
le maniche
c'è un fil rouge in questo mio discorso
il fil rouge è che credo che air france
col fatto di prendere ragazzi di una
dieta
acerba ma già avanti che gli permette di
andare a cimentarsi in un nuovo ambito
permette di espandere la loro cultura
il loro sistema di valori io sono un mix
di tre sistemi italiano dove sono nato
dell'americana dove ho vissuto e
lavorato e dell'anglosassone che è molto
diverso da quello che cerco di
trasmettere ai miei figli
è una nuova cultura forse più al piano
più ampia che prenda un po del meglio
degli altri
in modo tale che ogni volta che dei
ragazzi parta parte con un bagaglio più
ampio possa ampliare ancora e credo che
ogni volta che proprio la parte sia
veramente un mondo migliore perché ci si
capisca un po meglio
io mi occupo di turn around questo è
molto soft per me ma quando io vado in
un'azienda
non conosco io sono l'underdog sono
quello nuovo che arriva la nuova cultura
cielo allora gli do portare parte della
mia cultura in questa azienda parte dei
miei valori
ma devo prendere anche dei loro valori
perché le aziende non si stravolgono
io sono molto grato intercultura perché
mi ha permesso un viaggio che altrimenti
non avrei mai potuto fare ma il mio
viaggio
se io ringrazio tutti quanti voi perché
avete condiviso